>> Welcome to the session,
just after lunch.
I think people would
be trickling in here
because some of them
got lunch late.
But hopefully we'll see
a stream of people
coming in soon.
So, this is a session
on free inference and
instinct training,
breakthroughs, and implications.
We have a Stellar set
of speakers here today.
Matthai and I are
chairing the session.
We're just going
to set the stage,
introduce the speakers,
and hear from them.
So, in this session,
our aim is take
the blinders off and fire
the imagination of
the systems and machine
learning community.
Much of the community has focused
on speeding up training,
making it more efficient,
making inference as
cheap as possible.
Most of the work has focused
on deep neural networks.
We want to ask the question,
if all these problems are solved,
what should be we
looking at next?
So, we want to do this at
various levels, the
algorithmic level,
hardware level, what new hardware
should be we considering,
and frameworks and applications.
What are the new applications
that we should be considering?
Not just the standard image
classification or
translation applications
that have been driving
this field for the past
couple of years.
So, in this context,
we have four speakers here today.
If you want to look at
the universities,
they represent, CMU,
MIT, Berkeley, and Stanford,
and MSR too, recently.
So, five organizations
among four speakers.
More importantly they're
all experts in ML theory,
in algorithms, systems,
hardware, and applications.
So, we're very, very
grateful that you're here today
to share their thoughts with us.
I'll let Matthai, introduce
our first speaker,
to kick us off.
>> So, our first speaker
is Michael Jordan.
Who's the Pehong Chen
Distinguished Professor,
in the Department of Electrical
Engineering and Computer Science,
and the Department of Statistics,
at the University
of California, at Berkeley.
Professor Jordan, is one of
the leading forces in
the machine learning community.
It's a broad statement but it's
actually true across a lot many,
many different areas
of machine learning.
He's known for his pivotal work
in broad set of areas,
bridging, computational,
statistical, cognitive,
and biological sciences.
In particular, his work has been
central and understanding
the statistical foundations
of machine learning,
in addition to
developing algorithms,
and lot more downstream work.
So, without further ado,
here's Professor Michael Jordan.
>> Okay. Hi, did you
get my mic on now?
Okay. So, I gather this is
an systems focused crowd.
So, I will have that in mind.
My overall message is going
to be machine learning,
in great growth mode right now.
It's not one thing,
it's a whole bunch of different
kinds of related challenges.
So, I think about not trying
to build a single database,
or Unix, or something.
I like one tool, that solves
all problems in the field.
It's really more like tools.
So, think about someone
who builds houses.
They have a screwdriver,
and they have a hammer,
and they have a saw,
and all that,
and that hadn't changed
over the centuries,
and it's not going to change.
So, there's not be one tool,
this is a bunch of tools.
So, I have a lot of respect
for systems people,
and I really want to continue
the partnership
which is emerging.
In fact, when I first
went to Berkeley,
I was coming in as a
machine learning person,
this is in 1998.
They said, well, let
me join the AI group?
I said, "No, I know
nothing about AI,
and I don't really care,
I don't want to build
artificial humans.
That's not interesting to me.
What I want to partner with
is the systems people,
because they've got
a perspective that
I really respect and I want
to learn more about it,
and I think, there is where
the power is going to be."
They pretended to want
a label me AI over the years.
I've never worked on
vision robotics and again,
I don't really care, I
shouldn't say this on a video.
But I really care about
the engineering systems that
really changed the world,
really large-scale, move
data around, and all that.
If it has vision or movement,
that's fine, but it's not
my main focus. All right.
In fact, my perspective
on what's happened in
the last say, 20, 30 years,
it's a bit different from
the story you usually hear,
that it's all about neural nets
to computer vision.
So, I think first of all,
20 years ago, it was
about the backend.
The fraud detection was really
really important in the
history of machine learning.
It really worked and
it really changed
the business model for Amazon
and a lot of other in the banks.
We wouldn't have
Amazon today if they
hadn't been able to solve
it with Random Forest,
actually, early
classification systems.
Supply-chain management.
How do you have an Amazon if you
can't get all the
pieces together to
build all the parts
for a billion products
to serve hundreds of
millions of people?
Well, you model all of that
with machine learning,
that was done back then.
So, after all those systems
had been built this,
this was partly systems building.
They had Random Forests,
really built as
really good systems.
People started to
think, what can we
turn that onto the frontend.
Can we have humans,
their data, in the loop?
Can we build
recommendation systems,
and so on, and so forth.
So, I think, that's
what happened next.
I think, what we're in right now,
it's really what I
would call end-to-end.
It's not that there's been
a revolution in the technology,
and yes, there's a lot
of data and all that.
So, in some domains,
that's impressive,
but it's not that different.
What it really is that we have
some end-to-end capabilities now.
You can see you can build
almost as a commodity,
a speech recognition system.
It's an end-to-end system,
it takes in the waveform and
outputs something like text.
It doesn't solve the problem,
but it's a useful commodity
for all kinds of other things.
Similarly, with vision
problems and so on so forth.
So, end-to-end, is
both good and bad.
It allows you to build
a whole commodity,
on the other hand,
it couples everything together
in really complicated way,
and it makes it hard
to actually build
systems around those
kind of capabilities.
So, I don't think it's
the model going forward.
So, I think what's missing
right now is actually
what we're seeing
emerging, the
economic perspective.
You make intelligence
systems by having lots of
dumb local decisions in
a market with bidding,
and pricing, and all of that,
and out of that, starts
to emerge intelligence.
So, first of all, I don't
like the word intelligence,
I've said this in lots of talks
because we don't have it,
we don't understand it,
and we're not really
build it into our agents and
all that, they are
not intelligent?
They're taking in
data and mimicking
what they see in the data, right?
If we're ever going
to get intelligence,
it's going to have to have
some economic principles,
because a system that brings
all the food into
San Francisco, every day,
to have every person
and every restaurant
have all the food they need
at the right place at right time,
that's an amazingly
intelligent system.
But as you know, there is
no intelligence in
any point, in that system.
Everybody's just
thinking about should
I bring another head of lettuce
into a particular street address.
So, that's for me
what's happening.
Now, I read an op-ed,
recently, in this talk.
It's inspired by that op-ed,
if you haven't read that, I
would love to have you read it.
I do think that, it's important
to start to use this word AI,
in a more sensible way.
It's being used as an intellectual
wild card in my view,
when anybody doesn't understand
what they're really talking
about, they say AI.
I should say I think
Mark Zuckerberg
has done that better
than anybody.
Sitting in front of
Congress saying AI,
whenever he didn't
know what else to say.
I think we need to move beyond
the usage of that phrase
in that way.
All right. So, it was
originally McCarthy,
and these others, who had
this human imitative perspective.
Would it be interesting, and fun,
challenging, to make
a computer act like a human.
So, let's try to
imitate the human.
I don't think that's
what actually
happened over the last 50 years,
I don't think we've done
that, I don't think we can
imitate humans at all.
But what's really happened
is we've built IA systems.
We built systems that
augment human intelligence,
search engines, the translation,
and so on, augment
our human intelligence.
That will continue, and it
uses data, and it uses actions,
and it uses models,
and neural nets,
or whatever you want to do that.
But I think, the bigger picture
which we're seeing
emerging is what I've
been calling II,
again, none of this
is invented by me,
I'm just trying to put
a highlight on it.
It's Internet of Things,
needs data analysis, and
statistics, and decision-making.
So, not just taking in data
and crunching it but making
a large numbers of
federated decisions in
a context of
large numbers of agents,
hundreds of thousands of agents,
simultaneously doing things.
That's what we're
seeing emerging.
That's not the classical
AI perspective,
you have one agent making
a decision with
all the data it has,
and maybe making
a sequence at best.
The real world is 100,000 agents
making a bunch of
correlated decisions,
which can be good or bad,
like the financial system,
or the medical system, or
the transportation, or so,
that's the world we
should be having
more intelligence in and
we're not really thinking
enough about that.
Okay. So, let me just actually
skip this slide, I'm
just saying about.
I don't think with
human-imitative,
were not as far along as
everyone seems to think.
Even in vision, the systems
work pretty well with
pictures on the Internet.
They don't work well when
we got in the real world.
You can train them up with
huge amounts of labels,
and humans effort.
So, Tesla's doing that to
build self-driving cars.
That's fine, you can probably do
something in
that particular niche.
But we don't have systems that
really understand
the visual world,
the way we understand the verbs,
and nouns in the world not
just picking out
a few things and images.
So, it's a great field,
computer vision,
and it's not over.
It's going to be decades before
we start to get
somewhere with it.
So, we're not there
yet, and that's great.
But here's the main point,
or it's one of my main points,
is that I don't think
human-imitative II
is the right goal.
It should be to build
really large-scale systems,
that take care in data,
and make all kinds of decisions,
and all kinds of scales,
maybe for people, maybe for not.
But it's that system that
we were trying to build.
I do think about domains,
not like vision or robotics but I
think about medical domains,
where you're taking
in all kinds of data,
all around the world,
right this moment,
and decisions are being made for
people's health right
this moment,
and all those things
should be related.
So, that if you discover
something good for Jeff,
and Jeff is similar to me, that
should immediately apply to me.
If we start to make errors,
we should control
those so we don't make
too many errors and we
worry about provenance of
how the data was collected in
this particular situations is
still relevant for
this situation.
All the things you think about
like in the banking industry,
about how you move money around.
Think about doing that
four things like
medical decisions.
So, think of all the
systems issues there.
So, that's not really AI, but
it's really, really important.
So, just kind of
phrase I like to say,
"To make an overall system
behave intelligently,
it's neither necessary
or sufficient
to make each component of
the system be intelligent."
So, if you've ever did
statistical physics or
economics this is
very familiar to you,
but it's not enough to
express in our field, okay?
We want to think about
systems that are really
intelligent because they
maybe have market principles.
Here's another kind
of provocative point,
which is that if you ask people
what they're working on,
who are doing the current
in the current AI wave,
they often will say
an intelligence,
were trying to
understand intelligence.
Again, I personally don't think
that's what we're
doing right now.
And if you work on
natural language
semantics you're
starting to get there,
it's not that no
one's working on it.
But most people aren't,
just taking in data and
doing neural nets is
not intelligence.
But the other thing
they often emphasizes
autonomy, right?
I'm going to build
an autonomous system because
as if that's- so why?
Well, if I can build
an autonomous system,
I can sit back and say,
"Wow look at that, I did it."
It's intelligent and
it's autonomous.
It's a bragging point
that I was able to,
I don't have to guide it.
And if you're a roboticist
that's a reasonable goal.
But, for the rest of us, I
don't think it is at all.
We want to build a system
that integrates well with
the rest of us, right?
It shouldn't be autonomous.
Even a self-driving car
shouldn't be autonomous.
It should be communicating at
all times and all the
other cars around it.
And if a tree fell down and
you tell all the other cars,
and it should be highly
networked and all the incentive
should be set up so that
it goes down the street
at the right place that
can put on all the other traffic
and so on so forth.
It should not be autonomous.
It should be
exactly the opposite.
Okay, so I like to demote
autonomy is the goal I think was
a bragging point that will
rebuild autonomous systems.
We should brag that
we're building
highly interconnected systems.
All right, so here's
my favorite slide
for this particular talk,
there's some other things
I really worked on and
had been working on
for 10 or 20 years.
I consider these challenges and
the broader enterprise of
intelligent data oriented
decision-making systems,
let's call this II.
If you look at those,
most of those are not
the classical AI goals, okay.
Some of them are
like abstraction and
explanation, but a lot
of them are not.
So multiple decisions I
don't mean just a sequence,
I mean like 100,000
correlated decisions
in any given moment.
How do you do that? I'll
talk a little bit what that.
Systems that create
markets that don't just
create a so-called intelligence.
Dealing with uncertainty still to
this day things like
neural nets taken an input,
they produce an output,
and there is
no uncertainty
associated with that.
That's just dead
wrong for the future.
If you're gonna make medical
decisions for people and you
make an output that
says you have to
have a heart transplant,
I want to know how
sure of you that?
If you look at this other data,
do you know this thing about me?
Let's have a dialogue, and
that's part of the explanation.
What if experiments? Is all that?
Is gotta be surrounding
these systems.
So how do you do uncertainty
will things like
jackknife and bootstrap,
you resample,
you try out alternatives,
you look at what if experiments,
that's how you
assess uncertainty.
And our current systems,
I mean there are algorithms
for doing this but
our current systems don't
do any of that, okay?
Mostly. They're Bayes nets that
kinda put in uncertainty
with a prior probability,
but there's very little
frequent uncertainty.
Cloud-edge interactions
if your systems people
the importance of that will have
different knowledge and
different places when we have
cloud-edge interacting in
a different timescales.
And you've got to be
thinking about that,
how do you coordinate
all the different
out-of-date knowledge?
Abstractions, I must
emphasize that,
if you were to ask me why,
do you think we have
intelligence right now?
That's the main reason.
Humans are extremely good
at thinking up and I'm
thinking through abstractions.
That's what we do in computer
science really well,
but what we do in mathematics,
we do it in science,
that's what children
do extremely well.
And that's what
our current systems are just
incapable of doing, right?
I mean, yes, you have little bit
of features in neural nets to
do vision and that's
being called abstraction.
But that's far from what humans
that's really intelligent
system can do,
is think up and reason
with abstractions.
So it's a research problem,
that mean it's a
research problem.
It'll take a long time.
So let me just dig into
a couple of these again,
I think all of these are- it's
not that no one's
working on this,
not just my group
but many groups are.
But when you say AI
machine learning,
no one has all these in mind.
They just have mini batch
and distributed training of
neural nets and all that.
That's what AI is nowadays.
I want people to spread
their wings to some of
these other really, really
important challenges.
If you go into
a company like this one
or Alibaba in China or whatever,
this is the kind of things
they actually work on.
Most of them don't
work on a big system
with mini batch training
and so on and so forth.
All right, let me just
mentioned multiple decisions.
In real problems like
transportation to take an example,
you can't just have
each entity be autonomous
and thinking about nobody
but it him or herself.
You have to make a lot
of link decisions.
These decisions will
often interact.
Now, if there's no scarcity,
they don't really interact
that much but as soon as
you have scarcity like in
a real world economic system,
then decisions will start
to interact and you
have to worry about that, okay?
So, let's think about
systems that create markets.
Now, let me take just a very,
very simple example to
try to bring this home.
Recommendation systems to me were
one of the more powerful
achievements in
machine learning literature or
machine learning history, okay?
Before the current era,
they took and lots of data
and they help people make
decisions not just define
features and so on.
They help people
make decisions, what
books am I interested
in, and so on.
The way they work
still to this day
is that the decisions interact.
So, if I come in to
the Amazon system today,
they'll featurized me in
some way and they'll put
me probably into a neural net
these days and it will
output some recommendations.
There are some books, or
some movies, or something else.
Chris comes in later
they will featurized Chris
and they will put him
into the same neural net
and they'll make
some recognition for him
and those are totally
unrelated, right?
Well, so if you're recommending
a movie that's fine.
If they recommend the same movie
to me and to Chris and
all of the rest of
you in the room
or 100,000 people
that's no problem.
They just bring the bits
to everybody. No problem.
What if you recommend
the same book to everybody?
Well, it's price
still not a problem,
you can do what's called print on
demand but getting into maybe
100,000 copies of a book to
all the people who were read,
Hey, that's not an easy.
So it starts to become
just a little scarcity there.
But now, what if you recommend,
so you're trying to make
a really good recommendations
for things like
restaurant seats that not just
a bunch of advertisements,
but actually really bids
and link you up to
restaurants that
you might want be
inserted into maybe at
10% discounts and so on.
Well, you can't recommend
the same restaurant seat
to a hundred thousand
people, right?
You'll create
congestion. Instead you
have to load balance and you have
to do this really with a market.
You don't know what
people really want?
What their preferences are?
You don't want
the restaurants really have
available so you can't just
have the computer
know all of this.
So you have to build
a market where
the restaurants can bid on
the people and the people can
accept or reject and start
to create two-sided market.
What if I reckon, if I build
a really good app for doing
a how do you get to the airport?
Path finding. If
just a small number
of people are using
it no problem.
But if everybody's using it,
it might recommend
the same path to everybody
and I create congestion and
that's already happening,
you start to see that
happening with some of
the apps and sort of
these when they get big.
Well, you have to
think about that,
we can't start creating
congestion in our lives.
And here's another example,
is my favorite one,
is like in China
right now everybody's got
a little bit of money.
And a thousand dollar,
and they want to invest it
for the first time in their life
that might buy
a mutual fund or something.
Well, if it's there
now their apps exists,
which help people to make
their investment, right?
Well, if that app suggests
200,000 people today
to buy Microsoft stock,
the stock's gonna go up
artificially and that's
gonna move the market
and it's going
to destabilize the market.
You cannot do that.
Okay, all right,
so I hope you get
the sense this is real.
And at the same time,
there's the classical problem
of multiple decisions that's
more statistical and these
are quite orthogonal,
but you have to
solve both of them.
And I hope you all kind of
know about how you make
decisions now under uncertainty
not under scarcity.
If you make decisions
under uncertainty,
what you do is that you need
to make a decision here.
Do jellybeans cause acne?
Well, you randomly put half of
your people and
you do an AB test,
half the people go here,
they eat jelly beans.
Half the people don't
eat jelly beans,
and then you ask say
their skin condition
six months later and probably
there'll be no effect.
It will be within the error bars
and you can get a P value,
a quantitative assessment that
you're making
a real decision based
on the uncertainty
in this paradigm.
But the people don't stop there,
they don't just make one test.
They say, "Well, it's
just a particular
color that causes it."
So now, they do
the AB test 100 times.
All right, and now, by chance
alone they put people
just happen to have
bad skin condition and
the treatment condition
and they will look like
they have bad condition
after the test and it looks like,
"Oh, I've made a discovery
green jelly beans cause acne."
All right. Now, if you
had any statistics,
you know about this, but
you probably don't know
the solutions to this, okay?
And the software I know of
no software that anybody is
built in the machine
and ensure that
puts in false discovery
rate control,
which is kind of one of the
ways to deal with this.
So you can deal with this.
There's a notion called
false discovery rate
and it's not an error rate.
Error rate is
just a single number,
all right. It's a ratio.
There's a numerator
and denominator
and you want that ratio
to be small,
you can make it be
small by having
the numerator small that's
a classical error rate
going down or the new
denominator can be big, okay.
And so you can control
the fraction of
bad decisions in your entire
lifetime not just on one day,
not just the one decision
or a whole group of
people that you can have
that fraction be controlled.
Okay, so this is something
we've worked on at Berkeley.
Here's a very recent paper,
there's an algorithm
called DAgger.
There is the algorithm,
you can put that in
your software that will control
false discovery rate in
an online setting
across lots and lots of
decisions by making
the numerator and
the denominator be
controlled and it
doesn't require independence
and so on so forth.
So this is really you
can real math with
this kind of thing and
it should be done.
Put that together with
the economic perspective and now
there's wonderful research
challenges going forward.
I haven't seen a sign
telling me how much
time I have left so I'm a
little I'm calibrated here.
Five minutes? Okay.
There's a little bit
more about this
market's business.
So, people talk a lot about
AI killing jobs and
all that and there is
certainly some truth to
that but there's
people aren't talking
enough about ways
you can create jobs.
And I think that if you take
a market's perspective instead
of a classical AI
persuaded you can
start to see this
much more clearly.
So consider the music situations,
kind of this unclutter market.
More people are now making
music than ever before in history
because laptops slightly to make
really good music and some
people are really good at it.
On the weekend they
create great music.
They put it on
SoundCloud. All right.
And then they lose
control of it entirely
so then services like
Spotify or Pandora
will stream it to
large numbers of people and
more people are listening to
that stuff than ever
before in history.
Inside everyone
listening to Beyonce,
they're all listening this stuff.
But there's no market. There is
no connection between
the producer and consumer.
And so economic value
is being lost
probably billions of dollars of
economic value is being lost.
All right, so how do
you restore that?
Well, you use
machine learning and
economics together
to create a market,
right? How you do that?
Well, there's a company called
United Masters are very
famous musicians are
buying this and real tech people.
And so they just they partner
with sites like this and
they've looked at
the data flow they said, well,
there was a data flow,
I can put a price
on that and make it an economic
transaction out of it.
So I can create
a dashboard for musicians.
So if Chris is
making music on the weekend and
he drives a taxi during the week,
if he has the dashboard he
learns that in Austin Texas,
10,000 people listen
to him last week.
He's popular therefore whatever.
He knows he could go to Austin,
book a room and make $10,000.
And if he does that five times
during the year that's a salary.
So you don't have
to drive this taxi
or be professor during the week,
he can actually now
become a musician.
And this starts to scale,
you can think of now
hundreds of thousands or
millions of people in
various countries actually
starting to get a job
because they have
access to the data
about their skill set.
And now, didn't have to be
just music, it can be writing,
it could be art,
it can be all kind
of hair cutting and
so on so forth.
All right, so let's liberate
ourselves to think
about AI in this way,
that we create
connections where data
flows and we allow economic value
to be created not that we try to
replace human intelligence
with computers.
Last little point on
my last two minutes,
this is literally
advertisement is
that when you start thinking
about multiple decisions,
you do have to think about
sequences going forward,
not just simultaneous
which I've emphasized.
This is the area of
optimal control theory,
it's now often
called reinforcement
learning but it's just
optimal control theory.
I really want to hope
the system's committee
will start to
resonate to the need to build
systems that allow you
to do optimal control.
So, now you have to face
the fact that lots of
the tasks that you need
to run, I have very,
very different lifetimes
that you're going to
do a search process
through a sequence
of control actions and
sometimes you'll learn very
quickly that was a bad idea.
Another particular path
through the tree of
actions looks like a very
good idea for a long time.
So, if you start
synchronous processes
up and you have them all
wait for each other,
you're going to be
waiting way too
long in many situations.
So, the mapreduce paradigm
is not appropriate
for lots of these control tasks.
So, let me just sort
of skip ahead here is
just a little picture
to suggest this.
If you're trying to make
a simulated robot perform,
then what you're going to
do is try all the actions
of all the joints and everything
and try to build
a policy doing that
you do lots of what
are called rollouts.
AlphaGo did rollouts, most of
the so-called success
reinforcement are all based on
these rollouts in
a big, big tree.
All right, so we
have been working
on this system called Ray,
there's several students and
then John Stuart and myself
at Berkeley are leading this.
It is all about trying to
do parallel version of
Python where you can have
very heterogeneous tasks.
Some of them are very
short, some are very
long and there's
no synchrony anywhere.
It's all a big data-flow graph
where the data,
the graph itself is dynamic.
All right, so, I like to
think about this as in
Python you've got
functions and you've got
objects and they're
both really useful.
When people went
to MapReduce Jeff,
Dean and others, they kept
functions but they
threw out objects.
It was all functional
programming.
So, we want to restore
objects because we think
they're really are
important so Ray
is basically does that.
Functions are now called tasks,
they're distributed functions
and objects are now
called actors in the
classical language of actors.
So, they are stateful. So, we
built a system that does this.
Here's some performance,
I guess here
60 nodes were able to get up to
a million tasks per second.
So, task of low light
weight and they
can be used for these rollouts.
It is a working system,
I'll show you a GitHub address
here in a second.
Much work on scheduling,
local and global scheduling
and much work on
making sure that objects
are in the right place
at the right time.
Here's a little bit of
code using this it's
basically Python with
some annotators that
decorators that tell you that
some things are going to
be paralyzed and I'm not
going to show you
a little video of
his actually working but I
could just go back to
them for the last slide.
So, there it is on
the GitHub address
and by the way I'm going
to China a lot these days.
One of my big achievements in
China is to get some
of the companies there
to do open source development
and so there's companies doing
open source
development of Ray for
the first time ever in history.
So, I'm hoping that it'll
probably take off in China.
All right, so, to
summarize my message,
it's great era, don't just
focus on neural nets.
There's all other
problems and build
systems that focus on
all those other problems
because they will be
the ones that are actually
start to get used in industry and
have an impact on
the world and will start
to open up new research venues.
It's going to take decades
to get this field right.
This field is really not AI,
this field is really
a new engineering disciplines
like my father who did
chemical engineering in the 40s.
That was the thing
to do in the 40s.
Take the chemical principles
and turn it into systems,
factories and that's what
we're doing right now,
we're taking the principles
of decision-making and
data and analysis
and all that and
together computing and we're
building systems that make
human life better and
that's going to take
decades and I think
that's the enterprise
we're involved in.
So, let me just put that slide
up again this summarizes
what I think of some
of the challenges but
new ones are going to be
emerging. So, thank you.
>> Thank you Professor Jordan.
So, our next speaker
is Chris Ray.
Chris is an Associate
Professor at
the Department of
Computer Science at Stanford.
He's also affiliated with
the statistical machine learning
group pervasive parallelism Lab
and the Stanford AI lab.
Chris's research is unique it
sits at this intersection of
database theory systems
and machine learning.
Work from his group has
been incorporated into
major scientific and
humanitarian efforts
including IceCube
Neutrino detector,
Paleo deep driving
mimics in the fight
against human trafficking
into commercial products.
He co-founded a company that
was acquired by Apple in
2017 and I guess
Professor Jordan has put you
on the spot and you'll
be showing us
a musical talents too.
>> Yeah, I don't have
any musical talents,
Mike so I appreciate that.
What I'm going to
talk about today is
really pretty much in
line with what Mike was
talking about earlier which
is this drives it take
machine-learning and make it
into an engineering discipline.
One of the catch words
for this that's
going on right now
is a software 2.0.
Now the first time I
said software 2.0 I
have to admit I threw up
in my mouth a little bit.
I've soaked up about
as much Silicon Valley
as one human being can soak up
but even by
my standards like that
seemed like a little bit
out over my skiis.
But when I started
to realize as I
walked around to
all the different companies and
folks that are down there and
end up here in Seattle is
that the way people are
building software
is really changing.
That's to me going
to drive a lot of
the change for where
machine learning research I
think can have the most
impact and also build
the most interesting products
to impact the world.
So, if you've seen the
software 2.0 things the term
was coined by Andre
Carpathian a blog post,
but when you think about that
you probably think about
these really fancy applications
like translation,
robotics all kinds
of imaging and you
probably think about neural nets
and you wouldn't be too wrong.
One of the things
that kick this off is
this Google system that
shrink their language
translation system from 500,000
lines of conventional C
plus plus code down to
500 lines or so of
commodity machine learning code.
And that seemed 500 lines of
code more or less actually,
Facebook could replicate
it, Microsoft can replicate
and a graduate student in
Germany could replicate.
Something pretty exciting
at these as Mike
was calling them end
to end applications
are becoming
these insane commodity
so quickly is really exciting.
It changes where
you're going to put
the high-value PhD people
actually doing any work.
But what's been really
exciting as it's
not just those end to
end AI first,
Memel first applications.
There's a bunch of stuff
that's going on that's really
exciting that's taking
these principles
and applying them
all over the place.
I'll talk a little bit
about hollow clean that,
you have Helios and
Thiel are doing.
I'm taking these ideas
and applying
them to problems
like data cleaning,
and the extract transform
load process, and
data integration.
Andy Pablo is doing a bunch
of really cool work
on tuning databases
and tuning systems
using machine learning
and there's also
cool work going on
in networks as well.
So, this transition
where machine learning
works well enough that it becomes
a building block
for these systems,
means we have to think through
like how is software engineering
going to change?
And that's why I think
this software 2.0 is
an interesting paradigm.
So, what does it look like?
Well, it's a vague buzz
word so let me try
and put a little bit
of meat around it.
So, conventionally software 1.0,
you write code C plus plus
Python code and you compile
down to an ISA, right?
Machine-based instruction
maybe cuda compiling.
What's going on in software
2.0 is two big changes.
At the top and at the bottom.
At the top what's changing
is the abstraction, right?
How you actually build
these applications and
what you do is you
feed them training
data by enlarge.
So, that's the input that
you're giving to these systems.
Underneath what's really exciting
to me the first time in
computing since I've
been around in it is that
instead of compiling
down to instructions,
you're compiling down to like
a blast like data flow like call.
So, the hardware has a chance to
reach up and actually
change as well.
So, both the top and
the bottom of software
changing that seems pretty
exciting and interesting.
Okay, so, why is this happening?
Now conventionally people
focus a lot on quality.
They say, "Oh, I
built a system that
has higher than human
accuracy at test x,
y or z under some very,
very simple reasoning."
But what's exciting is
that actually this is
a way to build a lot of
products with
high-quality faster.
You have people who don't
have machine-learning PhDs,
who maybe have basics of
statistics being able
to build and deploy
high-quality products
in a small amount of
time and a speed to
develop them is amazing.
Also the maintainability,
rather than having
hand-tuned crazy
featurized systems,
they're building these systems
that are basically getting
all those low-level
details right for
them so they can focus
on building products.
So, that speed of execution
is just dramatically different.
What's also exciting is
that the deployment
story has changed.
So, neural nets have become
weirdly enough like a new JVM.
What I mean by that is that
there the language that you
compile down when you
want to ship code.
So, the hyper scalars,
Microsoft very
famously has a bunch of
great stuff like brainwave,
you can compile down to
hardware for neural nets and
once you do a bunch of
problems are almost
solved for you.
In particular, qualification
this process you go through at
any other hyper scalars
where you have
code you want to ship
it to the data center,
it gets much easier if
you've compiled down
to our neural net.
There's no allocation
on the critical path,
it's using a set of operators
that people have pre-qualified,
it's changing in that incentive
changes what engineers
want to build because they
can get their software
out there so much faster.
Now in a parallel life with
Kunle the father
multi-core and a guy
named Rodrigo Liang who led
1,000 person chip
group at Oracle.
We are actually some of
our research has being
commercialized to actually build
hardware for ML, which
is really exciting.
They're all underneath changes
about how today's
neural nets are trained
that are allowing hardware to
really radically change and
come up and meet
this abstraction.
But that's not what I'm
going to talk about,
I'm going to focus more on
that level of abstraction,
about how programming
and building
these things is really exciting.
So, the way we got into this
was about two years ago.
We looked at this landscape of
every week if you
remember in sort of 2016,
you would wake up
and look at archive,
and something else
would be posted:
this neural net does that,
this neural net does that.
It was a mad dash for innovation.
We looked at that and we said,
"Well, a lot of people are
working on that problem.
We want to work on
something else."
We bet that that was going
to become a commodity.
So, what we thought
was going to happen,
we didn't know
the term Software 2.0,
but we thought that deep learning
would basically plateau and hit
a commodity point
where people could
download and build software
with it pretty reliably.
So, we published this paper in
mid 2016 that we called
Data Programming.
They started to think about what
was happening up the stack,
and I'll tell you about the
software that we've been
building to implement this idea
over the last couple of years.
Now, the key observation was that
if you looked where engineers
were spending their time,
they weren't spending
their time building new models.
They weren't spending
their time actually
tweaking the underlying systems.
They actually weren't even
worried that much about run-time.
They just put it on some GPUs,
maybe, they go get a coffee.
Where they were spending
all their time was basically
creating and feeding
training data to these systems.
We thought, because we have
sort of a theoretical bent,
why isn't there
any mathematical structure
around sort of creating
training data?
Why does sort of Machine Learning
conventionally start with
data coming from god herself
and showing up in XY pairs?
Even though all those XY pairs
were generated by
a huge system that's consuming
all of people's time.
So, what we decided to
do is try and build
both mathematical and
systems models of what was
going on there with the hope
of both better understanding it,
and also hopefully
accelerating that process.
That's where this thing
Snorkel was born.
Now, very quickly, we stumbled on
one little technical nugget,
but there are many things
in this space
and I'll try and highlight them.
It was this key idea
that if you're going to
program Software 2.0 by
getting training data,
then maybe what was
holding you back in
some situations was leveraging
all the sources that
were available to you,
of various different quality.
So, what we started to do
or develop program abstractions,
really simple
program abstractions,
that could just talk about
different sources that were
informing your training data.
The mathematical
questions were to be able
to learn the accuracy
of those sources
and the correlations
among those sources
but without any
conventional training data.
Now, when we started this,
people were skeptical
saying like well,
we'll build bigger neural nets
and that will be the way
to higher-quality on
state-of-the-art tasks,
and we didn't care.
We said, "Well we're
going to go after people
who were just deploying
these things inside companies,
who were medical people
and all the rest,
who just needed to
build these products.
But what's been interesting
is over the last year,
the state-of-the-art for
things like ImageNet,
even a straight head benchmark,
have both come out of
tools that basically
allowed you to do more
weak supervision on top.
Facebook published
this thing about using
hashtags in various
different ways,
the AutoAugment people
are doing something
really cool that followed up on
some stuff that we were up to,
about learning data augmentations
and learning composition.
The point is that
these other signals to build
real products always exist
when you go to build
a real product,
but the benchmarks
don't capture them.
So, this engineering
challenge of bringing in
more and more signal
seems to actually
be catching on even
for the benchmarks.
Another thing that
I'll highlight here,
Ihab is in the audience,
you should definitely
talk to him.
He's the real expert here.
But on even on things like
conventional things
like data cleaning,
being able to apply
these ideas of
weak supervision and automatic
feature generation gives you
tremendous benefit in terms of
precision and recall compared
to the state of the art,
and Ihab is definitely expert.
He's back over there.
You should talk
to him about HoloClean.
They have a big website and
Theo is working on this as well.
So the point is, like this
stuff is coming but we don't
really have any
engineering abstractions
for it, and that's what
I'd like to build.
So, we started building Snorkel
led by two great folks,
one is Stephen Bach and
another great student,
Alex Ratner.
He's on the market this year,
you'll see his picture
many times.
There is his picture.
So, Stephen Bach is now doing
some stuff at Google
related to this,
and Alex Ratner really
led this project as well.
He's on the market,
please hire him.
Now, what I want you to show you.
First thing is
programming is changing.
So, not only can we
deskill many tasks,
that was our original goal.
Make it easier for more people
to use machine learning.
We also realized very quickly
in our conversations with
folks in the industry
that even the experts,
the seven-figure-salary folks
coming out of grad school,
they were having
similar kinds of problems,
and that even experts were
building and stumbling
on these problems of
training data generation and data
augmentation so we
wanted to study those.
The second thing
is, if you look at
classical questions around
supervised machine learning,
once you start to realize
that you don't have labeled data
that you can trust,
many different things actually
change underneath the covers,
about how you estimate
source accuracy
and correlations
and all the rest.
There's a bunch of really
classical theoretical work that
goes on underneath the covers
that we're really excited about.
The point is also there's
a lot more to do,
all kinds of things in
a pipeline: data augmentation,
ETL can be modeled
and potentially,
make it easier to
build applications.
I don't claim that we have
solutions that are even
very good but there are
first cut on these solutions,
and there's a lot more to do
to be able to build these
end-to-end machine learning
kinds of products.
So as I mentioned, this is
mainly a trolling slide,
data was the New Oil,
so training data is
the New New Oil.
I have no real idea why,
but it is really
a fundamental problem in
machine learning that you
need high-quality training data.
As Mike talked about, most of
the applications of
deep learning or almost
all of them really come through
a lot of supervised data.
As I mentioned,
traditional view is
that this data just falls
out of the sky and
you're given it.
But every application that
really generates dollars
that I'm aware of,
that training data was
created by a process: people,
software, all kinds of
things go into that process.
The key idea that I want
to show you is that
by modeling that process,
that provenance,
Mike used the same term as well,
modeling the provenance
of that process
actually can improve the quality.
That's the art project of it.
Is it possible that going and
understanding that pipeline
and mathematically modeling it,
does anything for
the downstream task?
Actually the answer is yes,
and that's what we've
been working on for
the last couple of
years in this project.
So, that's what Snorkel
is, it's all online.
We've been running
workshops about it.
As you'll see, there
are a bunch of users
for it which is exciting,
and we're modeling
these trainings,
that creation process, and
data augmentation process.
There's a blog and
all the rest of that crap.
All right, so how does it work?
I won't go into
too much technical detail
because we have
really short talk.
But please ask me,
please check out
the blog, and send feedback.
The first and simplest
abstraction that we
could use was this idea
of just functions.
So the idea was that,
what you're going to have is
a bunch of maps that took
your training set in and
then mapped to every point.
You can imagine it's binary
classification just to make
the discussion simpler:
yes, no, or I don't know.
I don't know it's critically
important by the way.
That's where a lot of
the interesting
intellectual work happens.
You would provide these functions
and they would
generate noisy labels.
You don't know their accuracy,
you don't know the
correlations of the labels,
but you know that
they're not probably
not of perfect quality.
Then, the second piece
is that you would
model those labeling
functions outputs,
and we chose to model them as
graphical models basically
for historical reasons and,
because we could prove
theorems about them.
You would try and figure out in
those graphical models what
are the parameters
of those models?
How accurate is every source?
How correlated is it with
those different pieces?
But the twist is, instead of
seeing a bunch of observations,
we would only see when
they agreed and disagreed,
and we would try to come up with
basically statistical models that
would allow us to conclude.
We could learn
those parameters provably,
and that's what basically the
program that we've been on for
the last couple of
years where you don't
actually get to see the value y.
Then finally, to take advantage
of all this nice deep
learning stuff,
we would then label
the entire training
set with accuracy.
So instead of getting a zero,
one or minus one, you get
a probability distribution,
and we would pass
that to a deep model,
and we would hope that that
uncertainty quantification
would allow it to
do a better job.
It would know to
trust some points
more than other points.
Now, I don't have slides here,
but you can definitely look
on the website about this.
This actually surprisingly has
big impacts on things like
natural language
processing applications,
cross-model applications,
all kinds of
different places where we've
demonstrated this on NLP,
in vision, and images.
This quantification
of uncertainty
actually seems to
help in some cases.
That it helps average great,
we're really excited about that.
It never seems to hurt,
and that's really the theory
that we've been
trying to work out.
More importantly, it
changes how people program.
So we've been basically giving
demos to people and allowing
them to write code on it
and a bunch of folks at industry,
in companies, I'll put
some logos up later,
we're actually using this
to build applications.
So, what we're after
here is trying to
understand how this changes
the programming model.
Again, we're at
the early days here.
We don't exactly claim that
we have the right thing,
but there's a lot that can
change when you start
to view sort of
your way of programming and
as generating training data.
So, let me give you
one example of something
that changes concretely,
it's actually a real person
who was building one of
the early versions
of the system using
a technique called
Distant Supervision.
So what they were doing is they
first wrote a bunch of these in
our terminology
labeling functions,
and they were very highly
accurate, very precise.
They labeled to say 10,000
points at 90 percent accuracy.
Then, they came along and said,
"I don't have enough
coverage in my model."
What I need to do is label
a bunch more points,
and they wrote a lower-quality
labeling function.
They label it and
say a million points
at 60 percent accuracy.
Now conventionally, what
you would do is basically
assume that all those labels
came from a uniform source.
As a result, what you
would have without
modeling that lineage
or provenance was
a set of data that
looked like it was
about 60.3 percent accurate.
You wouldn't remember if you like
that you have
that high accuracy pool.
Unfortunately, that will make
your overall model
quality go down,
which is extremely
bad and frustrating
as a user of this programming
model because you gave
the system more information
and then your quality to
the eye looks much much
worse, very very frustrating.
But, of course, as I've told you,
the fix is obvious.
If you remember where
these came from,
even if I didn't tell
you the accuracies,
you'd have a better job
of estimating which training
points you should trust,
which were high-precision
which were low-precision.
The art is to figure out
automatically what
those accuracies
are without seeing training data.
So, it's a very
frustrating experience
for users but it's the kinds of
things that we've been basically
publishing papers about.
So without going into
too much technical detail
here, basically, we can
provably learn the accuracy
of these labeling functions,
even among correlations
among them,
without hand-labeled data, and
even features under
which they work.
We can actually surface
features of them.
This is a sort of long, we're
not at the end of this,
we continually keep publishing
essentially improvements
to when we can learn,
and can we match
supervise scaling rates.
In many cases, we can match
In some places, we can
estimate correlations.
We may actually improve some old
supervised bounds of learning
graphical models structure with
this over the summer,
which is really exciting.
So this is the goal: change
the programming model,
and figure out what we can
offload and make automatic,
and understand
the minimal statistical
assumptions that allow us
to do basically carry out
this program, and that's
what we've been after.
One thing that was just posted,
it's been in use with a bunch of
our collaborators is doing
Multi-task Supervision stuff
and Multi-Task Learning.
It turns out real
applications don't have
just one classified output
by learning across
multiple tasks.
You can do a much better and more
robust job of dealing with air,
this is something that
we've put out and actually,
Mike mentioned Alibaba,
these guys are amazing.
If you're not paying
attention to Alibaba
compared to a US Company,
they're amazingly open.
They took our software when it
was like as alpha as possible,
used it, showed us where it
was used in their pipeline,
gave us a bunch of feedback,
and actually, in part,
some of the reason
we prioritize doing
the MTL stuff was because of
that amazing technical
feedback they gave us.
So, this is something
called metal.
It was just released and
the theory has gotten
dramatically cleaned up.
It's a little bit more
fancy than it was before.
But mathematically,
it's much nicer,
and it's practically quite
useful because you can build
these tasks at multiple
different levels of abstraction.
You can do parsing,
natural tagging for types,
you can do question
understanding all
in one model and
where one model is
weak another one could be
strong and you can actually
characterize this and why
it improves generalization.
A lot of that was done
10,15 years ago when
people were looking
at how multitask learning
was actually beneficial.
But in this new regime where you
don't trust your training data,
there are a couple of
twists and turns there but
it's a great software
abstraction, okay?
As I mentioned, the software is
only about two years
old but here are some
of the users and
sponsors and there are
actually many users who
are not on the slides.
We run these workshops and
people are able to build
something with it.
Again, this is not
great software,
this is graduate
students stuff but
people are able to pick
it up and actually use
it because it fulfills
this niche that there's
no programming abstraction.
So, our bar is pretty low
because there's nothing
else that's allowing you to
think about that training set
generation process
and I hope some folks
get excited in the audience
and build something
much better than what we have.
I was asked to give a hot take in
my last two minutes
and I would so I will.
So, one of the things
Mike was talking
about the difference between
AI and machine learning.
I think sometimes even learning
itself is not what
people actually want in
industry or it's overused
in a way that maybe leads
them astray and there's nothing
wrong with learning,
it's fantastic.
The generalization results
and all the rest are great,
but they're sometimes
misapplied or misunderstood by
engineers and it leads
them into a morass.
So, as I mentioned
ML's big impact to
me has been how it changes
Software Engineering
and deployment.
It's introduced this new JVM
layer and has allowed people
to programme far more easily
than they could before.
But a lot of what engineers
really want is just not to
have to tediously specify
every line of their program.
They really want something
that looks a lot more like
interpolation and so we actually
started thinking about
this a while back about,
well what would an interpolation
system look like?
Now conventionally,
if you talk to
an ML person which
is not formally
true for any reason
that the inequality
goes the wrong direction
to make this statement,
they think that an interpolation
implies that you're not
learning because
interpolation means
you're memorizing
the training set,
you're getting zero loss.
But these two things are
not actually in opposition.
You can actually get
robust interpolation,
you can get everything right,
you can do what
you're told and still
learn and generalize to
the rest of the dataset.
This is a pretty
interesting thing
because traditionally when
I watch engineer struggle,
they'll say things like
the model is overfitting,
but they'll have no idea what
they're talking about is
the error that's
on their test set
to their validation set.
It has nothing to do with
over fitting, but they sort
of adopt this ethos
that learning basically
means you have to make mistakes
and that's not true on
a lot of the products.
If 100 people ask
a question every day,
every assistant in the world
should get it right.
That doesn't actually happen.
So, I think
reliable interpolation
is one way to think about sort of
a next generation for
our learning and statistical
ideas can really play well.
Now, when I was thinking
about this I thought it
myself it was kind of heresy
but then I went
to ISMP which is
this great conferences
mathematical programming
conference and I was lucky
enough that Misha was
speaking after me
and as a result I was
reading some of his papers.
Misha stays at Ohio State, you
should check out his work.
He had this really cool stuff
which is a little bit
insider baseball,
but it's pretty
interesting which is about
how the kernel methods
can actually interpolate,
a family like interpolate
people knew that part
but could also get
minimax optimal rates.
So, like the best rates
you could hope for
these nonparametric
estimator is known
of a corresponding holder class.
This is really fascinating
because it means that
they're not on opposition,
so we have a chance of building
dramatically more
reliable systems than we
were building before
potentially, right.
So, that's an interesting way
to think about it.
Also, those minimax rates
are all up to
label noise and so as I
was talking about before,
the role of why we're modeling
label noise in
our construction process,
you could potentially get better
rates by modeling that noise and
that's a program that we're
carrying out right now.
If you haven't run
Misha's stuff, it's amazing.
His work is really one of
those fun times of being in
academia where you read someone
else's papers and send them like
frantic happy emails about how
exciting it was and I
got that chance to go hang
out with him in Bordeaux.
Definitely check his stuff
out I think it's super cool.
So, that's the end of my talk,
it's at the end of
the reality distortion bubble,
I don't know, but
what I wanted to get
across to you if you don't
know who the dog is,
you haven't been
reading enough reddit.
Anyway, but what I
want to get across
to you is that I
think programming
is really fundamentally changing,
its changing from
below in terms of
how we actually build
our applications and
this opportunity for
hardware to rise
up and meet this new
abstraction where there are
huge number of high dollar
workloads that are going into
a fairly narrow but still
kind of general pipeline,
that's really exciting.
I talked a little bit just as
proof of concept that hey,
there's more stuff
we can model and
the process that generates
the data for machine learning.
That's all Snorkel is really
about and the auto augment staff.
All that staff is really
about what goes into the top,
can we model more of that
instead of having
it as a black box,
what are those models look like?
We showed a first cut,
but there's a lot more to do.
Thanks so much for
your time and attention.
>> I forgot to
mention that I'm sure
all of us have
a bunch of questions,
we're just going to do our Q
and A session at the end with all
the four speakers up here.
So, yeah please hold
on to your questions.
So, our next speaker
is Vivian C. Vivian is
an associate professor
at MIT in the
Electrical Engineering and
Computer Science department.
She's really one of
the world's leading experts
in energy of signal
processing algorithms and
more recently has been looking at
A6 for DNNs and machine
learning algorithms.
Prior to joining MIT,
she was a member of
technical staff in RND Center
at Texas Instruments,
where she was a part
of the GCT video
coding committee in defining
the high efficiency
video coding standard
and for this she received
the primetime Emmy
engineering Awards.
So, she's raising the bar.
She's raising the bar really
high for these awards.
Emmy's and Oscars and Oscar next.
>> Okay, sounds good.
Anyway thank you very much
for the introduction.
So, the focus of my talk will
be a little bit different
primarily going to
focus on how do we enable
energy-efficient
computing at the edge
for both deep learnings
and beyond that.
This work is in
collaboration with a lot
of my students as well as
other collaborators at MIT.
So, I'm going to
try and cover three
key messages in my talks.
The first one, we
are going to talk
about the limitations of
existing efficient DNN
design approaches,
then we're going to talk
about looking beyond.
We'll talk a little about DNN
accelerators but can we get
acceleration by looking beyond
the accelerator itself,
and then looking at
other opportunities of
doing inference at the edge
beyond DNNs in general.
So, very briefly, what
are the limitations
of existing DNN approaches?
So, we know that in over
the past couple of
years there's been
a huge amount of effort to
enable energy
efficient processing
of deep neural nets primarily
because it's very desirable
on the edge devices.
So, within my team,
we've been spending a lot of time
building tutorial material and
surveys about this topic and
through this process we actually
found there were
several limitations in
the existing approaches
that I want to
highlight for
the research community.
So, the first thing
is that because
there's been a huge amount of
effort both on the algorithm,
the hardware side particularly
in algorithm side,
we've seen things like network
pruning where you make
the network sparse.
A lot of different neural
network architectures to make
it more compact and
also reduce precision.
In this particular set of work,
primarily the focus has
always been on reducing
the number of knots and
multiplies and accumulate.
So, computation as
well as weights,
but one question that we
really have and we're
looking at the edge is
does this translate
into energy savings
because that's what
really directly matters.
I mean we do know that we
look at the computer architecture
itself or where the energy
actually goes and mostly
goes into data movement.
Primarily, through
the memory hierarchy.
So, really what matters is
the order by which the weight
or the data that goes to
the neural network passes
through this memory hierarchy and
the data flow of
the overall movement.
So, in some sense you can
say that the weights and
the operations are
not all in all equal,
it really matters how they
move through the system.
To model this some of
the recent research within
my group has been to
build up a modeling methodology
to model data movements.
So for example, here
this is a model that's
based on our iris accelerator
where you can take in
various DNN shapes
as well as the sparsity of
the inputs and the weights.
You can get a breakdown in
terms of where
the energy is actually
going from layer to layer and
where in the actual system.
So, using information like this,
one thing that we first
want to figure out
is where is the
actually energy going
and what is the first
thing I want to
really highlight is
that the number of
weights alone is not necessarily
good metric of the energy itself.
There's many different types
of data movements that go
on within the system itself,
many different data types.
For example, if we look at
Google and we know that
weights account for
maybe 22% of the energy
from data movement but we can see
that also feature
maps with input and
output also affect or
significantly affect
the energy of the system as
well through data movement.
So, we really shouldn't
just be focusing on
the number of weights
in terms of trying to
estimate the energy cost.
And so, one of the thing
that I really want to
emphasize or push
is that the idea is
that we really what we want
to do is rather than taking
weights or number of
operations as a metric
that we want to reduce.
So, they're really easy to
calculate by looking at
the neural network itself.
If we really care about
energy or latency we
should directly target
those particular metrics.
During the design of
the neural network itself.
So, we can show for example,
one example of this is the
energy aware pruning approach.
The idea here is that if
we the layers based on
the energy consumption
and let's say we start
pruning the layers that
consume the most energy first,
we know that as you prune more,
accuracy tends to go down.
So, you basically want to spend,
get the best bank for your buck,
spend the money where,
spend the pruning where
it matters the most.
If you do that as
opposed to just removing
weights that tend to be small,
you actually get
better energy savings.
So, compared to
a typical magnitude based
pruning approach which is
actually quite effective,
you can do even better with
energy where pruning by
really removing the weights
where they actually matters.
So, we can see here
for example on
AlexNet about a 1.7 x
reduction in energy,
by driving really
the algorithm design
based with the energy metrics
as opposed to just looking
at number of weights.
One challenge of course
is that what if you don't
actually have an energy model
available for you,
can you automate this whole
process by actually taking
direct metrics from
an actual platform itself?
So, this is some work that
we've done recently with
Google's mobile Vision Team
and the idea here
for net adapt, is
that rather than.
Again, using an energy
model to estimate
the energy or the latency,
we can take direct measurements
from a mobile platform itself.
This will incorporate things like
the effects of the tool chain,
and if you have some
proprietary hardware where
you don't actually have
the low-level details of,
you can still take
that information,
those metrics that
you care about and
insert it into
the net adapt algorithm.
And automatically adapt
the algorithm to really minimize
either latency or energy
or a combination of both.
These are much more directed
towards the metrics that
you actually care about
when optimizing
the system as opposed to
again just counting the weights
or counting number of apps.
To just show a case
the impact of this,
if you look at
the trade-off in terms of
let's say here accuracy
versus latency.
So, the top left is better,
you can see this is net adapt
applied to mobile net
and this is actually
the smallest version of
a very small version of mobile
that which is more
difficult to prune.
You can see is that you
can get up to about 1.7
x reduction in
latency for the same,
around this same accuracy.
This is really because
you're driving
the algorithm based on
latency as opposed
to that based on
reducing the number
of operations.
So, again the message here is,
really can you incorporate
the direct metrics that
you care about latency,
energy or whatever
your system metrics
are directly into
the optimization of
the DNN itself as
opposed to other metrics
like compute or
number of weights.
Another thing I just want to
highlight more looking at
the hardware side is
that now that we have
many of these energy-efficient
DNN design approaches
from the algorithmic perspective,
the one challenge from
the hardware perspective
and when you build accelerators,
is that there is no guarantee
as to which DNN approach or
algorithm and algorithm designer
will actually use and try and
launch onto your hardware.
So, what's really
important also is to
be able to develop
hardware that's
flexible enough to exploit
these different features
of these DNN algorithms.
So, one of the challenges that we
see from doing this
is particularly
in the design of specialized DNN
hardware and they often rely
on certain properties
of the DNN to
achieve the high
energy efficiency.
So, very typical
specialized DNN hardware
will use an array of
multiplies and accumulates.
One benefit of doing that
is that you can reduce
the memory access by
amortizing the reads
across the MAC array.
So, for example, in
this particular depiction
when I read the weights,
I can reuse them across
multiple columns
of the MAC array.
When I read an activation,
I can use it across
multiple rows of the array.
So there's a lot of
reuse here and as we
mentioned before memory
access is very expensive.
So, the more you can reuse,
the more you can reduce
the energy costs
and make the system
more energy efficient.
However, as we mentioned a lot of
these network architectures are
continuing to evolve and change.
So, usually the challenge with
these particular types of
architectures that we saw before
was that the reuse and
the reutilization really
depends on specific
properties of the DNN.
So, for example, the
number of channels,
the feature map or batch size.
So as a result,
when you build hardware
that really relies on
certain properties of
the DNN but then the DNNs
are varying in terms
of their architecture,
it's not going to be
enable your DNNs to
be or your accelerators
to be efficient
across a wide range of
compact DNN architectures.
The other thing to also
consider is that we
often want to scale
up the size of
these arrays for
your accelerators
and so it's going to
become less efficient
if you pin the utilization on
certain dimensions of
the DNN and then you
scale up the array size,
the likelihood is the utilization
of your array is going
to reduce as well.
So, another thing is of course we
mentioned that pruning and
sparcities they're also
effective method of potentially
reducing the cost of
processing these DNNs
but this can be
challenging if
you're going to use
this pinned array structure.
So, one of the focuses
of our next generation
eyeriss is really
trying to balance
this flexibility and efficiency,
what we want is to be able
to support a wide range of
filter shapes with
large and compact.
Then many different
types of layers,
both convolutional layers and
fully connected layers but
also things if you
start thinking like
mobile net depth wise layer is
also important to
support and then
often tends to be
challenging because
the number of channels is
significantly reduced.
You want to be able to
support a wide range of
sparsity both dense and
sparse since you often
don't have control as
the hardware designers to
the degree of sparsity
of the neural network
that's going to be
deployed on your device,
and then you also want your
architecture to be scalable.
So, for example, if I scale up
the number of
processing elements,
I also want to see that
my throughput also scales up
and that my energy efficiency
is also getting better.
So, what's really important
is that you're able to find,
like if you have a very small
compact neural network,
you have the flexibility
to find where
or what dimension you can reuse
as much data as possible.
So, by having
a more flexible dataflow
and NoC and which we'll
talk about next for our C2,
you're able to get
over an order of
magnitude savings in terms
of both speed as well
as energy efficiency
compared to V1.
Just to give you an idea
in terms of how we're
getting this flexibility
and Eyeriss V2,
primarily the main
focus is to have
a much more flexible dataflow
and in particular we extend
Row-Stationary Dataflow into
Row-Stationary Plus and
what this really means
is that enables you to
do more spatial mapping
and all dimensions
of the PE array,
so that you can exploit
more data reuse in a multiple
different layer shapes.
So, for example,
previously if you're
looking at let's say
a depth wise layer,
you really have very
limited in terms of number
of channels you have but
if you can actually also with
Row-Stationary Plus not only
fill up your array
based on filter width
but also channel
groups and you can
really utilize your array much
more fully and then
have higher throughput
and have higher efficiency.
To go along with
the more flexible dataflow,
what you also need is
a more flexible NoC where
node C to actually support
all these different
configurations.
In particular, you want to be
able to have a NoC that you
can deliver multicasts when you
ignore to exploit
high data reuse.
So, for example, if you
have a very large network
like AlexNet where there's
a lot of reuse opportunity,
you want to have a
NoC that can find
that reuse and make
good use of it,
but at the same time you also
want this NoC to be flexible in
the case where you have
layers that don't
have as much reuse.
So, for example, the fully
connected layers or the
depth wise layers in
the compact networks and then in
that case you want you're NoC to
be able to do unicasts and
deliver a high bandwidth
just the same throughput.
Then of course as I
mentioned, there's
no real control in terms
of the degree of
sparsity that you have,
so you also want
to make sure that
your hardwares or you're
NoC is flexible off to
support both sparse
and dense layers
and both the weights and
activations for the various
different configurations
rather it be convolutional layers
or the fully connected layers.
So, that's basically
what you can do
from the DNN accelerator
point of view.
So, really again
the message is to have
more flexibility from
your hardware and to really to
drive the design of
your neural net algorithms
using real metrics such
as latency energy.
The one thing though
is sometimes there's
a certain limit in terms of how
fast you can actually
make your accelerator.
So, one thing to do is also look
beyond the accelerator itself and
find other opportunities to
accelerate your processing.
So, I'll give one
example of why it's
important to look beyond
the DNN accelerator,
what opportunities
there are particularly
in the space of super-resolution.
So, one important
application that
super-resolution serves on
mobile devices is again taking
low-resolution images and making
it to high-resolution image.
This can be very
useful if you want to
transmit a low-resolution
image because you
have very limited bandwidth
or because just the sizes
that are screens
continue to grow.
So, it's very useful for
the viewing experience.
However, on a mobile device of
course again you have
very limited compute.
We know that these days
a state-of-the-art
super-resolution
algorithms often are CNN
based and in fact if you were
run them on very high
resolution images, for example,
from HD to alter
HD their degree of
compute for these
super-resolution
algorithms are going to
be exceptionally high
and they don't map well
very much to
these mobile platforms.
So, the one way that we tried to
address this is to develop
a framework that we can use
to accelerate
the super-resolution,
we call it FAST and the main
idea is that you're
basically in search
different super-resolution
algorithms
into this framework,
we also taken the
compressed video and then
you find opportunities
to accelerate it,
primarily by exploiting
an interesting property
of the compressed video itself.
So typically, if you look from
a super-resolution point of view
at a video where you
actually view it as
a bunch of stacked pixels.
However, if I was
the person who previously
worked on computer video coding,
the way that I typically
look at compressed videos,
is in terms of
a more description of
the block structure
or the structures
of the pixels within
the video itself.
So, the one way where we get
really effectively
compressed video
is to describe the video,
figure out the
correlations between
the pixels within
the video itself, right?
So, in fact, the compressed video
itself is not
just a set of pixels,
but a lot of information about
how different pixels in the
video is actually correlated.
So, the goal here
is that can we use
this compressed representation to
help accelerate
super-resolution itself?
So, in fact, you can.
So what you can do is
rather than having
a bunch of Low-res videos and
applying super-resolution
to every single frame
of the low-resolution video.
What you can actually do,
is you can apply
super-resolution on only one of
the frames and then use
this correlation
information, for example,
motion vectors to actually
transfer the information from
one frame to what are
the high-resolution frames to
all the other
high-resolution frames.
You can generate basically all
the other high-resolution frames
without having to run
super-resolution on
every single one.
So, as a result
super-resolution is only
operating on a subset of
these particular frames.
This tends to be much more
computationally efficient
because this transfer
is very cheap,
it only involves basically some
bicubic interpolation
and again it
involves using
free information that you
already have in
the compressed video itself.
So, if you transfer from N frames
you'll just basically
get an Nx acceleration.
So, we verified
this particular approach on
why dataset primarily the
HEVC development dataset
of 20 different videos.
We're able to show that if you
transfer up to four frames,
is actually no loss
in terms of quality.
If you transfer up to 16 frames,
there's about a point two dB drop
in PSNR which is
not too bad at all.
Typically for these particular
types of applications,
it's really important
to actually look at
the visual quality itself.
So, shown here in the video are
three different renditions
of the super-resolution.
So, on the left-hand
side you have
the original SRCNN algorithm
with the highest quality.
On the right-hand side you have
the bicubic interpolation
and you can see by looking
at the text of
the cards that it's
much more fuzzier than the SRCNN.
However, then you have fast
in the middle which has
the same complexity as
the bicubic algorithm
on the right-hand side,
but you can see that
the quality of fast compared to
the left-hand side is
also very competitive.
So, the main idea here is
that while we can do a lot of
things to really accelerate and
make the DNN accelerator
more efficient,
there are other properties
that we can look
at beyond the accelerator
itself to improve the processing
or make the processing
more efficient.
In this particular case,
looking at much more
efficient representations
of the incoming data,
that's actually there for free.
So, one final thing is looking
Beyond Deep Neural
Networks itself.
On what are some opportunities
in terms of whether
the types of processing
that we care about at
the particular edge.
So, one of the
projects that we've
been working on within my group,
this is in collaboration
with Sertac Karamani
and Luca Carlone in
the AeroAstro department,
is how to build very low
power processing engines
for autonomous Drone navigation.
Particularly, Nanodrones, where
you talking about drones,
the size of bottle caps
or the size of a quarter.
So, in this particular project we
built a chip we call Navion,
that primarily does localization
and mapping at under around 30mW.
The real challenge is really
fully integrating all of
that processing on chip.
Because when you're
talking about such a
small Drone you can't have
so many external parts
or external components.
In terms of what
this Drone actually does,
it actually is performing
Visual-Inertial Odometry,
is basically taking
in an image sequence
as well as IMU measurements from
Inertial accelerometer
plus a gyroscope
as taking these two
particular inputs in,
and then try to determine one,
the location of the drone itself.
So, shown on the upper right
hand corner you can
see that based on
the visual data as well as
some IMU data is trying
to determine itself,
in the 3D world as well as
mapping the environment itself.
So, that's one of the key goals
for this particular type
of processing.
Really one important aspect
of this particular processing
has to take in,
as I mentioned the vision input
as well as the IMU input,
and you want to do some kind
of optimization of
the vision data as well as
the estimated state
from the IMU data.
Typically, this optimization is
done in the form
of a factor graph,
to help you infer the location of
the Drone itself based on
this incoming information.
Basically, this involves solving
a nonlinear least square
factor graph optimization.
You have factors that are
dictated based on the feature
tracks that you see from
your vision side as well as
any IMU measurements
that are coming in.
Basically, this is a large graph,
you're talking about
over 4,000 factors,
all where you're trying to
put this under a small drone.
Based on these optimizations,
you can kind of update
what the states
are and figure out
what the 3D Map is.
So, very similar to
the deep learning space,
you can also find
opportunities to exploit
things like sparsity to
reduce the computation.
In particular here, we look
at the fact they can exploit
sparsity you get 5x
reduction in memory,
which is very important
to the area cost of
these particular
devices and about
a 7x increase in
terms of the speed.
So, what I want to
show here is there are
other opportunities
other than DNN itself,
where acceleration
and the co-design
of both the algorithm and
the hardware can really
enable increased
energy efficiency.
So, to summarize, we talked about
the various different
design considerations
for deep learning at the edge.
The important thing
is to make sure you
incorporate direct
metrics such as
latency or energy
into the design of
the algorithm itself
to improve efficiency.
It's also really important
given the large number
of efficient DNN algorithm
techniques out there to
support hardware that
can really support
flexible data flows
and NoC to exploit
both the data reuse for
energy efficiency as well as to
ensure that your array is
fully utilized for speed.
It's also important
to look beyond
the deep learning acceleration
engine itself for
other opportunities to
accelerate your algorithms,
in particular you can look at
the representation of the data
that's actually coming in,
in this case super-resolution,
we showed that that
was quite effective.
Then finally, there are other
forms of inference that can
actually process at the
edge beyond deep learning.
So, we showed one example
of using graphical models
for localization and
mapping for Nanodrones.
That concludes my talk. Thanks.
>> Thanks Vivian. So,
our final speaker for
this session is Jeff Gordon.
Jeff is the research director for
the Microsoft Research
Montreal Lab and also
a professor of machine learning
at Carnegie Mellon University.
Jeff is very well known for
his work on AI systems that
capture long-term
thinking such as,
long-term reasoning, reasoning
ahead to solve problems,
planning a sequence
of actions and
inferring unseen properties
from observations.
He also has a very unique
perspective now as
the head of Microsoft's
latest AI lab in Montreal.
>> All right, thank
you very much.
So, I thought the title
of the session was chosen
very provocatively so,
I did my best to respond to it.
So, free inference
and instant training,
I'm not going to be able
to achieve either of
those but I wanted to talk a
little bit about how to
make these things faster
without sacrificing quality.
>> Might not be projecting there.
>> It was projecting
a second ago.
>> What number are you on there?
You're on number 11 looks
like. There you go.
>> All right. So, I'm going
to take as given that
the right answer that we know
a right answer for
inference and that
it's basically Bayes rule is
implemented in graphical models.
But this answer is
incredibly expensive,
and there are a lot
of people who have
done a lot of great research on
making it less
painfully expensive,
but it's still pretty hard
to pay the cost sometimes.
But if we can, it's
got lots of benefits,
among them being that
every node and edge in
your model has a semantics,
probabilistic semantics,
which helps you
design a model that
takes the best advantage
of your data,
helps you figure out what
your model is doing,
debug it when
something goes wrong.
On the other hand, unless
you've been living under a rock,
there are deep nets and
they are much faster,
at least naively,
because they work,
basically their
inference process is
a whole bunch of
simple matrix operations,
fixed quickly computed
non-linear functions.
The training as well
can be very fast,
it's basically
stochastic gradient descent,
as opposed to Markov chain
Monte Carlo algorithms
that are harder to
design and may take
a while to converge.
So, not much semantics
necessarily in these things,
but they're fast and
they're very successful.
So, the question I'm going
to ask in this talk,
is can we get the
best of both worlds?
So, can we design
deep nets that look more
like graphical models,
or vice versa,
and take advantage of
both the semantics
and the scaling to big data.
So, what we'd like is
a model format that's both
practical in the sense of
a deep net, practical,
you can train it
quickly on lots of
data and get high performance,
but we'd also like
to import some of
the interpretation
from Bayes' rule.
So, I'm going to take
as an example inference
on a chain graph,
just a whole bunch of
random variables
connected in a line.
So, for this chain graph,
if the standard Bayes' net
is a hidden Markov model,
but if you're
a neural network person,
forget about
hidden Markov models,
you're going to use a
recurrent neural network,
maybe an LSTM, or a GRU,
or something like that.
I want to say that RNNs are
basically Bayes' nets already.
But what do I mean that they're
sort of Bayes nets already?
So, if you're a recurrent
neural network processing
along a sequence over time,
at any given point,
you have to have a notion of
what the future is
going to look like.
You have to be representing
a probability distribution
over the future.
That's true no matter what
your architecture is because
as long as you're able to
predict the next observation,
you can then sample
from that distribution,
feed in your own prediction,
and move yourself
forward a step and
keep doing that until you
have a rollout of the future.
So, you're representing
implicitly
a prediction about
the future which
is the point of Bayes' rule,
is to give you a representation
of that distribution.
The update rule for
recurrent neural network,
you didn't learn
it by Bayes' rule,
you learned it by let's
say backprop through time,
but if you learned it so
that it performs well,
it has to be doing
Bayes' rule approximately.
Bayes' rule is the right answer
so it has to be doing
approximately that.
So, what we'd like
to do is make this implicit
representation more
explicit in order to maybe
gain better performance and
behavior of these models.
So, the first step
is that I'm going
to suggest making
this implicit representation
of the future more explicit.
So, in addition to predicting
your immediate next observation
the way an RNN would always do,
I'm going to suggest
that you should
also predict statistics
of the future.
So, things like moments of
the next few observations,
or the count of
the number of observations
out of the next ten
that are all one,
or things like that.
If we have enough features,
if you keep adding on
independent predictions
that you have to make,
after some point, you're going
to get that your predictions
are a 1:1 map from
your latent state.
So, your latent state
vector of your RNN,
uniquely determines
your predictions and
your predictions,
if there are enough of them,
uniquely determine
the latent state vector.
Therefore, they're
also a 1:1 map from
this probability
distribution that
we're trying to represent.
So, this representation of
a bunch of predictions of
expected statistics
of the future,
I'm going to call this
a predictive state.
A state because
it's a 1:1 map from
your actual latent state,
and predictive because it's
a bunch of predictions.
So, this idea sounds
simple but it turns
out to be powerful.
So, just a little intuition,
one example I would like
to use is a video of
a clock with its pendulum
swinging back and forth.
If you wanted to make
a predictive state,
you could directly predict
the next two frames
of this video.
Those two frames would
encode the state of
the clock in the sense
that they would give you
enough to determine the position
and velocity of the pendulum,
which is the physical state
of the system.
So, that's a visual example for
people who like
examples and equations.
Let's say we have
a hidden Markov model.
So, we have a transition matrix T
and an observation matrix O,
and we look at the expected
next observation given
the current states,
so that's the observation
matrix times the latent state.
The button next to observation,
one time in one future,
is O times T times your state.
More steps in the future,
you keep including
more copies of T,
and if you stack enough of
them so that that matrix
has full column rank,
which you can always do
if you don't have
excess useless states in
your in your hidden Markov model,
if you have enough of that,
then that vector of predictions
is a predictive state.
So, just the expected observation
over the next few time steps.
So, you can add
this predictive state
to a recurrent neural network,
and doing so there's
no necessary reason that it
has to make things better.
It's an inductive bias,
it's a statement
about the problems
we expect to encounter.
But empirically, it seems to
help prediction accuracy.
So, the graph I have here is
from this paper by
Venkatraman et al,
it's Drew Bagnell's group,
where if you use
a particular algorithm for
generating a
recurrent prediction,
in this case of an action in
a reinforcement learning problem,
you get one level of quality.
If you add as well
this predictive state notion,
and train it to optimize that,
this is an example of
multitask learning,
and this inductive bias makes
your performance go up.
Oh, but there's a problem, right?
It's still a recurrent
neural network.
When you train it, it's
still going to get
you probably to a
local optimum, right?
So I've heard a lot
of people claim
that neural networks and
stochastic gradients
have the nice property that
all local optima are
approximately global,
but the one exception won't,
there may be more exceptions.
But one certain exception to
that is recurrent networks.
It is very, very possible
in my experience to get
into a very bad local optima
when you're training a
recurrent neural network.
Okay. So, what are we going
to do to try and fix that?
So, I'm going to propose that
we should try and bootstrap
from supervised learning.
So, empirically,
all of the people making
these claims that
all local optima or
global are talking about
supervised learning problems or
at least many of them are,
and empirically it's true.
There seemed to be fewer worries
about local optima when
you're training
a supervised neural network.
Theoretically, it's also true,
for example, if you have
a linear predictor,
a recurrent one can
have local optima but
a supervised one
cannot. All right.
So, let's try and
borrow that property.
So, the bootstrap is
going to work like this.
We're going to predict
our future features
directly from a fixed window
of history instead
of recurrently.
So, that's going to be
a supervised learning
problem, right?
At any given time step
you have a past and
the future and you predict
the future from the past,
but it's suboptimal because you
have a finite window
of memory, right?
You can't remember anything for
longer than the length
of that window.
So, that's step one.
Step two, now I've got
a bunch of predictions
of the future and
I'm going to take
my prediction that I
made of the future at time t,
and I'm going to add
that as an input
when I predict the future
at time t plus 1, right?
So I'm going to change
my predictions together,
and this allows
infinite memory because
a given observation will
influence my prediction,
and that prediction
can then influence
the next prediction in
the next one and the next one.
So, it sounds like I'm making
things recurrent again,
but I want to emphasize that
I'm using past
predictions, right?
I used an earlier version of
my model to make
some predictions.
I'm adding those to my training
set and their fixed,
so I've not backpropagating
through them.
So, I've gotten rid of
recurrence but I've
introduced a new problem,
which is that the
training distribution
changes across iterations, right?
If my model changes,
then my predictions change,
which changes now because
my predictions are input
at the next time step.
I've changed my training
distribution and so I've broken
the assumptions of most
supervised learning algorithms.
So, step three is going
to fix that problem.
We're going to fix that problem
using imitation learning.
So, a quick detour inference,
you can think of it as a
very special markup
decision process,
a very special reinforcement
learning problem,
where the state is the
predictions we've made so far.
Our action is to make
another prediction,
tack it onto the end of
our list of predictions,
and our cost is the sum of
the errors we make
in the predictions.
So, learning to do
inference is the same
as finding a good policy
in this reinforcement
learning problem,
but the nice thing
is that this is not
a general reinforcement
learning problem.
We actually have an expert if
we have training data that
does a pretty good job that
gives us a good policy
to start from.
What that expert
does is every time
the expert is called on
to make a new prediction,
it copies that prediction
from our training set, right?
So, that expert is a good policy,
and so reinforcement learning,
when you start with a good policy
is actually much easier.
It's probably impossible in
some sense if you don't,
and probably possible
in a sense if you do.
In particular, we can reduce
imitation learning to
supervised learning which was
the visitor outcome from before.
We wanted to be able to
bootstrap off of
supervised learning.
So, it's going to do that
by a framework called
approximate policy iteration,
this captures a number of
different imitation
learning algorithms.
So, for those of you
who haven't seen it,
exact policy iteration in
your reinforcement
learning problem,
you look at every single
state and action,
so you should already see a
problem with this, right?
Exact policy iteration
requires you to loop
over all states and
actions in your problem.
Calculate some statistics
of the current policy.
How well it performs
starting from
each state-action pair and
some quantities you can
compute from those
including the advantage,
which is the difference
between the quality of
a given action at
a given state and
the quality of the best
action at that state.
So, we choose then
a policy which switches
to the best action.
The policy which
optimizes the advantage,
meaning the policy which picks
the action which has
the smallest difference
from the best action,
namely, the best action
at every state.
Now, this doesn't work
in a real sized problem
because you can't iterate
over all state action pairs.
You can't exactly calculate
the advantage function,
you have to estimate it somehow,
and you can't freely choose
a new policy, right?
So I just said that
my new policy separately set
its value at every state,
but I can't do that,
I have to work in
some hypothesis class
of policies.
So, instead, we're going to use
approximate policy iteration.
So, to do that what
we're going to
do is effectively
approximate each
of the steps of
policy iteration instead of
exactly computing this advantage,
we're going to estimate
the advantage function.
Instead of exactly
computing this new policy,
we're going to update
our policy within
some hypothesis class
to improve a criteria.
The same criterion we were
trying to improve before,
I just want to highlight,
so what we want is
the expected value under the,
if we follow the new policy
and we look at the states
and actions we see when
we're following that new policy
of the advantage that
we see of that state action pair.
So, we want to effectively
reduce the number of
times we're taking
suboptimal actions
in a given state
and reduce the amount by
which they're suboptimal.
So, to instantiate, this
is a meta-algorithm,
you can't code it in
Python or Ray or any of
these systems without saying
how we're going to estimate
the advantage and how we're
going to do the update.
But supposing that you
could implement it,
you would get
some nice guarantees.
I'm not going to go through
the analysis but basically,
what it says is
that, so this here,
this expectation is what
you're trying to optimize.
If you're able to
get it below zero,
then you're guaranteed that
your new policy is
better than the old one.
That's something that you
can empirically measure,
so you know when
you're succeeding.
And sort of qualitatively,
you'll succeed when you have
a policy that's not the
best in your class, right?
You can't expect to improve
it if you already have the best.
If the class is rich enough
that it can represent
an improvement and
basically training succeeds,
that you're actually able to
find within
your hypothesis class,
this policy that
causes an improvement.
So, there are a couple
of specific algorithms
within this class that
I wanted to point out.
So, one of them is called DAgger.
I just wanted to
point out this is
not the same as the DAgger
that Mike presented.
I also wanted to point out,
I think we got the name first.
So, anyway, but we capitalize
the first two letters,
so you can tell the difference
between the algorithms.
So, it stands for
Dataset Aggregation.
So, the details aren't important,
except that what you
wind up doing is solving
a classification problem on
every iteration using what's
called a no-regret learner.
So, no-regret learners
are very nice.
If you're interested in
machine learning theory,
you should read up on
them, they're cool.
But the key thing to know about
them is that neural nets
are not one of them.
So, what this lets you
do is if you're willing
to restrict yourself to
the class of no-regret learners,
this gives you a way that has
some nice results you
can prove about
the improvement in the policy.
So, the other one I wanted
to point out is instead
of completely solving
this classification problem
using a no-regret learner,
it's also possible to
write an algorithm that
does a gradient step.
Much like SGD but with
a slightly different rule for,
you are calculating
the gradient of something else.
So, another catchy acronym
for this one's called AggreVated.
Differentiable,
that's the D version of
aggregate values to imitate.
One of my collaborators has
an excessive fondness of
good acronyms as you can
probably tell from
the past two slides.
Anyway, so the point here is
that you don't have
to restrict yourself
with this newer version
of the algorithm
to a no-regret learner,
you can do it with
any differentiable learner,
any learner where you
can make your gradient
descent update step.
So, in both of these cases,
what we've done is we've taken
a supervised learner and
we've trained our neural network
not by backpropagation
through time,
not as a recurrent
neural network,
but by reduction to
a supervised learning algorithm.
Empirically, this
actually seems to help.
So, the print is
probably too small to
see, but for example,
on this plot here,
so if you start from
random initialization,
you train several
different algorithms and
they all get up to
some level of performance.
Then, for example,
this green line is
the vanilla version of
the algorithm that I just
described and you start
with a smart initialization
and you can do
more gradient descent
to get yourself
better and it winds up in
a better local optimum.
All right. So, how much time
do I have left? I'm done.
Okay. So, in that case,
I think I'll stop here
and just summarize and
say that basically what
I'm trying to do is
to figure out how to
take these deep networks
that are so efficient,
so useful in practice,
and make them both on
semantics that's more like
a graphical model
and to try and gain
some benefit from doing that not
just the benefit of
interpretability,
but benefits in actual
practical performance as well.
So, thank you.
>> We are going to
request other speakers
to actually come up,
and then if anyone in
the audience has questions,
please raise your hands.
We have mic owners here
who will get a mic to you.
>> All right. Where do
you want us to stand?
>> Oh, actually maybe
there in the spotlight.
>> In the spotlight, of course.
>> As we're figuring this out,
they're still questions from
the audience maybe
I can start off.
I had a question about
strong guarantees.
So, it looks like
there is this trend.
Finally, we've reached
a point where they're
programming the tools including
programming language support
that will allow
us to hold programs responsible
for what they're doing.
Strong guarantees from programs.
There's always been
this move, model-checking,
and systematic testing, but
no verification in
terms of approve.
So, you fail at
the compile step as opposed
to running your program.
Now, unless you're hit
with this wave of models,
that can potentially
replace programs,
are learning from samples.
It's not clear how
robust they are.
So, is this taking
us back a step?
We've just begun to
take a step forward,
and you want to be
taken a step back.
Do you have an opinion on this?
>> Let me push back
against software 2.0.
I mean I think it's not
a replacement of
software 1.0 at all.
It's just a different tool.
So, it's a commodity.
You can get a neural net
to learn how
to maybe recognize fro
classid image to visual scenes,
and say there's a person
in them or not.
You can do that
with software 2.0.
Otherwise, gather all the data
of all possible scenes
and all possible people,
and put them into
a big neural net and
they get better and
better over the years
and shape that.
Okay, but that thing has
done no abstraction.
It's not a predictable module
for all purposes.
It's just a little piece. It
sounds like an accelerator.
So, I don't think of it
as replacing at all.
That said if you have
static versus dynamic,
I still think dynamic
is that way to go.
You're not going to
see all the things
that can happen in
the real world.
We interface with the real world
a static program.
You can prove that
the things could do
exactly the thing
you hoped it'll do,
but what you're hoping
to do is exactly wrong.
So, you get a great proof
that it's going
to go to the wrong thing.
So, no. Computer scientists
have got to realize that
the next wave they're
interfacing with
the real world with all
of its vagaries and
not proving that what happens
inside the computer is what
you thought would happen.
>> I think there's
some really exciting work
that's going on at
Stanford from Dawn Song,
who just came over, and
other folks who are working
on validation and verification.
They call themselves
the AI safety group.
They're trying to
say even if you have
a black box view of what's
going on underneath the covers,
can you do higher level sort
of proofs on it?
So, Michael [inaudible] ,
who actually worries about planes
turning left right and center,
actually has some
pretty exciting stuff
where he's able to say, "Yes.
Indeed. We can verify
that the plane when it claims
it's going to turn left,
for control theory will turn
right." So, that's one issue.
So, there are
a whole host of places
where people have
paid the cost for
verification to build
software products
for a long period of time,
but the trend seems to be going
the other way in my mind.
I mean when Python
first came around
remember everyone said,
"Oh. It doesn't have types.
It doesn't cache anything
at compile-time.
No one's going to use it."
But the amount of stuff
that's built on top of
it is truly staggering.
Right? So as Mike
says, and I agree,
the pieces that people are
building right now with
these neural nets,
they are kind of
these individual components.
But those individual
components and
those individual
functional teams are
building most of the applications
that are being built
at the hyperscalers.
So, I think in one way where
we're in agreement is we
need abstractions to be able
to compose those things,
and understand them, and
validate what's going on.
We need some notion
of modularity.
But I think it's
a new notion of modularity.
It's not the traditional
software 1.0 wasn't that great.
It's not like we solved all
these problems and didn't
have bugs and understood
what was going on.
It was kind of a shit show,
I think is the technical term.
So, the comparison in
the bar is pretty low.
I think the interesting
question and
where we probably are
in agreement is: Okay.
We have these great
pattern-matching engines.
They allow us to do
certain tasks that are just too
difficult to program
tediously line by line.
How do we build them
into realistic systems
that don't fall over in the wild?
Right now, we have Machine
Learning systems that are
deployed that make
stupid errors day-in
day-out hundreds of
times a day where you
can't imagine why
they get that wrong.
So, we got to do something there,
and I think Mike's right.
It's probably going to be
some amount of abstraction
of how do we program
these things.
But you're no longer programming
like jumps and for-loops
and things like that,
you're programming at a much
higher level of abstraction,
and it's a challenge for
computer science to get there.
>> My phone fails to auto
complete my name every time.
So, yeah, that's an example.
>> That's why I
don't want to spend
on Twitter a lot recently.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. It's pretty simple.
>> Yeah.
>> So, I have to
agree with this idea
that abstraction is going to
be the really important thing.
I don't think we're there yet,
I don't think we know
the right way that
AI systems are going
to do abstraction,
but you're going to
be able to compose
AI systems with one another.
I think this is, it's
a grand frontier for research
because I think there are a bunch
of really interesting ideas
out there but nobody's solved it.
>> Are there questions
in the audience?
Someone's waving at me
telling me we're out of time,
but I have one more question.
So, this is about
sort of benchmarks.
So, it looks like
there are a lot of
new algorithms people
are coming up with
highlighting their
awesomeness including
new hardware that people
are coming up with.
People have begun to take
the baby steps of defining
benchmarks so that it can
be some common substrate
that you can use for comparison.
So, you might have heard of
MLPERF as being an example
where we're collating
a bunch of working models
that different people
can actually
use as a benchmark.
But that's just a
first small step,
do you have thoughts in what
the benchmark should look like?
What's missing in there that
ought to be there from like
an individual perspective,
and not just individual
algorithms like
image classification?
>> One thing I'll plug
there is Matei Zaharia,
and Peter Bailis did a huge
amount of work on DAWNBench,
which came out and
now is moving in to
be a part of the MLPERF effort.
I think they had a
great visionary there
that I understand about.
Trying to hold people's feet
to the fire and
understand how to
bring back that level
of indirection or
abstraction that allows
people to optimize models
independently of
their applications.
We might need
a great reference to this,
and I agree the current set of
end-to-end models is
kind of a disaster
because you can't work on
one component without affecting
every other component,
and so benchmarks are one way
to potentially drive like "Okay.
We're going to
understand this level."
I haven't given it as much
thought as those folks.
You should definitely
ask Matei. I think he's
giving a talk in
the next session.
He's thought about this
a lot more deeply.
But the current
benchmarks are kind of
just the traditional horse races.
They're just "Hey, this
looks like a spec benchmark.
We want to see how fast we go."
There's nothing about
sample efficiency.
data augmentation.
There's just the inklings of
what's going to be around
mobile performance which is
a huge and massive area.
That's something
that's coming online.
So, benchmarking
that's closer to what
people are building is
an obvious direction to go.
I hope that [inaudible]
is one of many efforts.
I hope it doesn't get controlled
by just corporations,
and assume I've had a great tweet
about exactly that point.
That academics really
should be playing
a bigger role at being
neutral arbiters of "Hey,
here's what's interesting
and exciting."
Matei and Peter deserve
a lot of credit for going
out there and doing
a lot of unglamorous work
to get that thing running.
>> So, on that note, I
think like benchmarks are
important in terms of
defining the workload,
but also in terms of
defining what are
the metrics that people
should actually be measuring.
I think often there's a lot
of games that can be
played in terms of,
let's say, you're
running the same net.
But whether or not you
batch or not batch,
whether or not you're
deciding how much do
you rely on off-chip memory,
on-chip memory,
thinking more from
the mobile side of things,
it's really important to
give a comprehensive set of
metrics to validate
those particular benchmarks.
Not just the workload,
but what are the
metrics that should
be evaluated as well should
also be incorporated.
>> Yeah. I, first of all,
just need to emphasize again.
This is not one little field.
This is not databases.
This is huge it's all about
everything having
to do with all of
AB testing is included in here,
all of control theory
is included,
all of natural
language processing.
It's just this is massive.
It can't be a few benchmarks.
So, with Chris, I
totally agree on this.
>> Yeah.
>> It's good if there's a need
for a lot of them and lots
of further testing of
various aspects of it.
I agree with her too. It is
about not just what's
inside the computer.
It's about what's
in the real world.
The loss function should be
things that people care about,
so they should have
utilities there.
So that they should be worried
about dangers that you can
get into the situation
you're going.
I mentioned provenance early,
and we just kind of bring
that back out a little bit.
You know, database people are
the only ones I know about
who I talk about this.
But I think they have so
much more they could do with
it because provenance is that
a piece of data should
be tagged with where it
was found and various
metadata about it.
In a statistical setting,
it's question is how relevant
is it? So, you're a doctor.
You're trying to decide
treatment for me.
Well, you look around, is
there any other people I
have ever seen like
this person? All right.
That's provenance, and how
relevant is that data I
collect on that person,
and that person's living
over there in Africa,
is it relevant or is it there?
That whole collection
which is relevant for a
decision in a particular context
that's provenance broadly writ.
So, thinking about benchmarks
for that I [inaudible].
But it is a key part. It's one
of a 100 key parts
of the problem.
So, yes, we got to be
quantitative and all that,
but let's definitely not get to
a few benchmarks and
have them be neural nets
applied to images
too soon because
that would really kill
off the bigger picture.
>> One thing I should
also plug in there
which is an honest
thing is there's
a great paper by Percy
Liang and his co-authors.
Percy is amazing. It is
about where QA systems
kind of went awry.
There is a SQuAD benchmark
that people put out. I
mean Percy [inaudible].
He did this whole thing
about SQuAD with Pranav,
and then it got kind
of deemed to no end,
and so Percy being fantastic.
>> It clicked through
rate has gotten
gamed the world's society
is suffering from it.
So, definitely
we're talking about
real metrics that matter
to human beings out there.
>> He published a paper that's
in ACL that I would advise
checking out about how you
can fool these systems,
and how they don't exhibit
any of the understanding no
matter anonymous
corporations putting out
beating human-level metrics
I won't say which one.
>> Not in Seattle, I guess.
>> Not in a rainy climate.
But I think that
that introspection only
happens with a benchmark.
So, you could view it
as negative and say,
"Oh, preview the benchmark."
But actually, it drove
a huge amount of work,
and said, "Oh, actually the
interesting challenge
is over here."
Forced researchers to say,
"Hey, I thought all these
features were important.
They didn't show up at
all in performance."
But this robustness thing is
really the place where
we need to focus on.
So, I think these benchmarks
are going to play
an outsized role in
a really empirical science
now going forward.
>> I think that's right. I
think you have to think of
a benchmark not as
a fixed target,
but as a way to discover
the next benchmark.
>> Right.
>> As soon as you
figure out how to
cheat the first benchmark,
that guy's designing
a second one.
>> Right.
>> So, I guess we're over time.
If people have questions,
please continue
the discussion in the break.
So, I think the next session
starts at three.
Let's thank our speakers
once again for everything.